Lincoln didn't exist in a historical
vacuum obviously he's the and he's part
of a spectrum of thinking on slavery in
that era at one end of the spectrum are
the people we know as abolitionists the
Frederick Douglass the William Lloyd
Garrison's the Wendell Phillips these
were people who demanded the immediate
abolition of slavery and the
incorporation of blacks as equal members
of American society now their role was
very important in the polishing slavery
they were not a very large number but
they helped to change the public
discourse about slavery which is
critical on the other end of course of
people like John C Calhoun and others
who just thought slavery was the best
kind of system and should be permanent
but even within the anti-slavery
spectrum you had these abolitionists on
one end and on the other end you had
people who believed who wanted to get
rid of slavery but thought it would be a
long long process might've Lincoln once
said it would take a hundred years to
get rid of slavery and they couldn't
really conceive of blacks being members
of American society they talked of
gradual emancipation of paying the
owners for their slaves and very often
of colonizing them outside of the
country Lincoln starts out at that end
of the spectrum but during his life and
particularly the civil he moves toward
the abolitionist position by the end of
the Civil War
he's obviously presiding over the
immediate abolition of slavery with no
compensation no payment to slave owners
even though slaves legally a property
and at the very end of his life he's
talking for the first time publicly of
giving the right to vote to at least
some african-americans in the south so
that's a whole different picture than
sending him out of the country now
they're going to be there as part of the
political system so what's interesting
to me about Lincoln is how he moves
along that spectrum too many people take
one moment in Lincoln's career or one
letter of one speech and they say there
is Lincoln but you can't pin him down at
one spot he's that's part of his
greatness he grows he changes he in a
rather in a period of radical change he
himself is able to you know rethink his
ideas and many presidents including some
recent ones aren't able to rethink even
when you know events seem to suggest
they may be
the wrong track